あっはいこんにちははじめ社長です皆さんが僕動画編集っていうのをよくやってるん
ですけども
クロマキー合成というのがあるんですよただがわかりやすい米を言うとですねハリー
ポッターで出てくる透明板ってあるんですか
あれ実はですねすごい簡単でどうやっているかと言うと緑色鋳物を超えて被ラギラって
知っているだけで当面
なるんですよそのや珍しい説明したくないんですけども簡単に言うとよっ
なんか緑色鋳物を透けさせることができるんですよ例えばじゃあ簡単にましょう
ここにスイカがありますとはいえまだ他のスピーカー透明をしてますできますよ
えっ
はいどうでしょう頭になってると思います透明性が多分黒いセンサ健在かなと思います
まあこれが俗にクロマキー合成
そう我はねユーチューバーまたは動画編集している人からすると結構簡単な構成なんす
べきですね
見たでいろいろんだったら透明にできる今もう3でのドレスいいかも透明にできるし
まあ僕からやすいいただき
いますともハリーポッターの桃米マンと何でも進めてきますからね
入ってくらいですね実はね緑色妹の使うとすごい簡単なんですよそこで初めは思ったら
ですものは何でも緑色にしちゃうと王命になるのではないか
そう私は思ってしまいますチョイ技で今日はですね僕の編集技術を使ってどこまでもの
透明にできるかいろんなものを緑色にして
行ってみようと思います暗いぞ思うよ
[音楽]
ああ
me
えーん
car
me
[音楽]
tan
ああああああ
[拍手]
[音楽]
ブーダッキキュッ球技 wisdom 的なから笑う
ばっきゅん日言え水玉的なああああああ
[音楽]
ni
me
おっん
[音楽]
ni
me
[音楽]
応用よヨーヨー足を得ますねっ
富士言います立ロックフリーパッケージ
じゃあるって言うぞいや言い飽きるッ
[音楽]
応用四葉は水曜4 s えっ
me
teame
car
rar あっ